[Music]
okay i'm gonna spend the next five
minutes talking about the most overrated
productivity hack on the internet in my
opinion which is the pomodoro method you
might have used this technique
effectively in the past i certainly have
but i now have come to the point where
i've found that in the long term it
turns out to be a lot worse for my
productivity and work so in this video
i'm going to talk about three main
reasons why i personally think that this
technique might not be as good as we
think it is very briefly the pomodoro
technique is a study or work method
where you work for a set period of time
usually 20 minutes and then you take a
five minute break and you repeat this
again and again now the first reason
that i hate it is because it tends to be
the anti-flow method of productivity a
flow state is a state where we are 100
enthralled in what we are doing we have
lost perhaps all sense of time and space
and we are focusing purely on what we
are doing at the time the state has been
described by many psychologists and it
tends to feel deeply deeply fun and
engaging however it takes a lot of time
to get to this point usually a lot more
than 20 minutes so if we are limiting
ourselves by working for only 20 minutes
at a time we can essentially never reach
flow and even if we somehow tend to
reach flow very early on we will be
interrupted and stopped as being called
out of the state by a huge distraction
like a timer for a break means that then
we kind of lose our sense of working
very hard on something and then go back
to baseline of being distracted and
perhaps taking a lot more work to get
back into the mindset of working in
general so even though i don't reach the
flow state every single time that i am
studying or working in general i do like
to think that i have the option to do it
and it's much more likely that i do it
if i don't have a timer to stop at some
point the second reason i usually
dislike the pomodoro method is because
it creates a dichotomy between working
and taking a break and this is hugely
problematic if we create this
distinction then we are saying that work
is in a way a thing that is bad or a
thing that we don't enjoy or a thing
that we have to do and rest is something
that we like a thing that we enjoy and a
thing that we want to do and even though
most of us would agree that this is
actually the state well if we know that
we have to do work we might as well
enjoy it there are some very interesting
studies that were done with children
wherein two groups were given tasks to
do one group was rewarded for the task
and one group wasn't the children who
were rewarded for the task in the long
term ended up not enjoying it and the
ones who weren't rewarded were just made
to do it with nothing good given to them
after ended up enjoying the task a lot
more and the reasoning that the
psychologists gave for this experiment
was that when children are rewarded for
doing something their brains start to
think oh i must not enjoy this task
because i am being paid to do it it must
be something that i don't want to do
well when they are not given a reward
the brain justifies this by thinking oh
this must be something that i enjoy
doing it because i'm doing it for no
reason or for no reward and therefore
they end up liking this activity much
more in the long term this kind of goes
against our theory of positive
reinforcement for things but this is
something that has been well documented
in child growth so for this reason i try
to apply the same method to myself where
i very often stop rewarding myself for
doing things i don't want to do and in
the long term i end up enjoying those
things more counterintuitively so with
the pomodoro technique because you are
rewarding yourself with a break or with
food or whatever you want to do or enjoy
in that five minute break then it makes
you subconsciously feel as though the
work is something that you have to do
and you really don't want to and you
really don't enjoy rather than just
forcing yourself to do the work with no
reward which will then make you think
that oh i must enjoy this thing that i
keep on doing for no reason third and
last reason that i deeply don't enjoy
the pomodoro method is that whenever i
put a timer be that a timer just for
food or a timer for working or a timer
for studying there's a part of my brain
that is paying attention to the timer
constantly a part of my brain which is
waiting for that kind of signal and that
alarm to go off and no matter what i
cannot focus 100 on what i am doing
because a part of my attention will
constantly be distracted on my phone or
on a kind of timer device that i might
have somewhere and i really don't like
this split brain thinking because then i
tend to be a lot less productive in the
task that i am actually doing if you're
constantly calculating oh it might be 10
minutes to go or oh i think i might be
halfway or surely can't be more than two
minutes left that's not a very
productive place to be so i'm almost
running out of time so i do need to wrap
this video up but this was my reasoning
as to why i don't like the pomodoro
technique and if you made it so far
thank you so much for spending this time
with me i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day be kind yourself and others
and don't believe everything you think
thanks bye
[Music]